hello everybody how's everybody doing
oh we were doing fine
check-in something things here to make
sure everything's okay okay here you
have a good day today so if you stay
tuned you might learn something
first I want to mention again I always
like to mention this we have a
conference in Osaka Zambia Zambia so if
you're interested in meeting some great
people having a great adventure well
it's about a month away a little over a
month away so get your tickets get ready
bring your bags and give me some great
people yeah
all I can say is don't miss it
we've had some great conferences in the
past always with great people the other
thing I want to mention is once again we
uploaded a book it's a free book you can
download it you can get up to speed on
the road model of light and gravity and
that's 160 page book if you have a
second language like some people have
already volunteered please contact us at
toca cockeyed hotmail.com and let us
know if you want to translate I'm
translating translating it into Spanish
these days and it's probably going to be
out soon okay I'm going to start a
Spanish channel stimulated really I've
got the channel already so we're gonna
have these transmissions in Spanish as
well and so what I want to cover today
is begin by covering some of the
comments that were made I always like to
do that get those out of the way because
it shows what people are not
understanding and a lot of people are
just the hit and run visitors they come
they hear a little bit see a little bit
superficially and they ask questions but
they haven't taken the trouble
of sticking around and finding out what
the site is about and so they just have
you know one of those impromptu
[Music]
questions in their minds and they just
ask it you know so but anyways I do want
to address those issues anyways because
other people have the same questions in
their minds they probably don't ask them
but they don't understand really what
one is saying okay so here it goes the
first one okay we have this fellow he
says I'll start with the word object
okay good
bill states that an object something
which has shaped yes that's that's what
we propose that's the definition of the
word object for the purposes of physics
he uses us weren't specifically several
time because it means you can't question
him about it no it's not that you can't
question me about it's that first we
need to define the word object for the
purposes of physics and all I'm saying
is this is my definition if you've got a
problem with it then you got to
challenge the definition and the best
way that you can do it is by proposing
an alternative definition and that's
where everyone everyone who comes in
criticize it lacks no one comes and says
look this is what I proposed instead of
your definition nobody says that
okay so let's first justify that we
absolutely need to define define this
word for the purposes of physics okay
that's that's going to be justified okay
you can't just say well you need to
redefine the word I don't know table
well do we for the purposes of physics
well maybe not but the word object is
absolutely critical if we're gonna talk
about mechanisms and if we're gonna try
to explain how mother nature runs her
shop okay so yeah the word object needs
to be justified here it is okay here's
the universe okay with nothing in it
okay do you see any motion do you see
any activity do you see any phenomenon
happening there
well I don't think so you know there's
there's nothing there okay that's that's
why you don't see anything in there no
universe has to have matter okay has to
have stars gases something moving okay
and all motion is mediated by objects
okay you have to have it an object to
conceptualize motion in fact you have to
define the word object before you define
the word motion in physics okay so let
me get this other one up here if I can
find it here it is so we end up with a
golden principle this this what this
takes us to physics requires an object
you can't do physics without an object
what would there be to study if you had
no objects in the universe not not a
single atom what would be movie whoa
what are you staring at what do you
imagine what are you visualizing there's
nothing new so you need objects the
universe so-called universe that's work
we use right to refer to that stuff out
there in the universe black stuff plus
all these little stars that we can see
at night all those are stars planets
gases atoms that's what they are you
take all that away there's nothing
there's there's nothing happening
there's no gravity no nothing because
there is nothing there okay so you need
an object to do physics that's a
non-negotiable premise you start there I
call it the golden principle okay you
need an object therefore you need to
define the word object for the purposes
of physics which is what this fell as
well as so many others never do they
never tell you what an object is they
just tell you what it ate and they don't
like the shape criterion because it
destroys their religion that's why I say
the scientific definition of the word
object destroys all religions
once you learn exactly what that means
means you have graduated from rational
physics you have to understand what that
last corollary means okay yes
once you define the word object we give
you an example
God disappears because God has to choose
God cannot be an object em and a concept
God is either a concept or an object God
either has shape or God doesn't have
shape which is it which is your God and
if it doesn't have shape if it's a
concept then you're praying to a concept
and if it's an object you know if you
want to being sensing in addition has to
have location so yeah you need to define
the word object for the purposes of
physics when this follow defines the
word object will address some of his
other issues the other issues are
irrelevant if he doesn't know what an
object is okay so that's the first word
he needs to define okay and here's a
second dominant I think from same fella
that says I like the rug bill carries
around with him at conferences this rope
and I guess he's referring to this rope
my magic rope Wonderwoman
lassoed that's my rope okay
unlike this rope right the
electromagnetic rope that this simulates
that this represents is intangible yeah
okay
definition of the adjective intangible
is unable to be touched yeah okay good
and or not having a physical presence
wrong that's not that's the mathematical
physics religion notion of in tangible
intangible does not mean it's not
physical okay and again if the only
criterion is shape then there is no
provision for touch or for see okay
let's understand that and again it's up
to him to define an object otherwise
he's got to go back to the definition of
object that's whether it's it serves no
purpose to answer any other questions
that he might have unless he can tell us
what an object is in his religion okay
that's that's a scenic corner he's got
to start there he's got to toss what an
object is so we can follow what he's
talking about we don't know
right now what he's talking about and
see he's talking about tangibility he
says so first issue how can a physical
entity like an electromagnetic rope be
intangible
it's like saying an object is a concept
please explain yeah very easy to explain
it very easy to explain here it is first
uh not all objects are are touchable but
he is using the see touch criterion by
default you know there is he's already
he hasn't defined a word object he
doesn't pay attention to the fact that I
defined it as shape and he's already
moving on and he says oh we can't see
her touch where did this come from where
did this touch and see criteria come
from who who why did he come up with
that where does he have a definition of
the word object involving the word
seeing touch okay so if you have that
criteria and we put it next to the rope
which is here okay object is that which
has shape okay it does the rope have
shape yes okay it has the same shape as
the rope that you buy at the hardware
store two strand twined rope
so yeah rope has shape there it is in
fact all ropes in the universe even in
the line of the Klingons and had better
half shape because the word shape that
but the word Grove refers to that which
has shaped always like the word table
tables always a physical object even the
imaginary ones okay because they have
shape not because you can touch them and
the electromagnetic rope does not have
the same properties as the Rope of our
everyday experience you can't use the
senses okay specifically see and touch
so it's irrelevant for him to talk about
intangibility when intangibility is not
a criterion for an object okay and
here's why we excluded completely you
cannot use any of these criteria okay to
define the word object for the purposes
of science for the purpose as a physic
you cannot use see touch mass volume
made of you know it's the known as me
rheology what what the table is made of
not us not a scientific definition -
lady you cover here today or temporal
parts you know involving time can't be
the subject of a sentence that's in
ordinary speech that's what a noun is
for the purposes of ordinary speech for
the purposes of physics a noun is that
which has shape only if it doesn't have
shape like the word orbit is not a noun
for the purposes of physic it's a verb
and so we need to understand all these
things okay and we're didn't finish in
which we're hopefully going to cover
today is not a noun there's no such
standalone physical object called
infinity so you cannot talk about
infinity on its own like I'm gonna talk
about in my physics dissertation I'm
gonna talk about infinity no such thing
okay and the others color you cannot
confuse it with the word exist and
certainly an object is not that which is
3d because we have 2d objects as well
and we have to cover those in physics as
well we have to identify them so if it's
a 3d or a 2d object all you're doing is
putting an adjective in front of the
word object you're saying this one is 3d
and that one's 2d but you're still
talking about an object you're just
talking about different it's like saying
this is a black object and that's a
white object you have the word is object
that what you need to define so you
can't use 3d or 2d as criteria and so
since he mentions touch let's find out
why we can't use the word touch as a
criterion that's the only one I'm gonna
address okay here it is summary why
touch is not a valid criterion for
defining the word object for the
purposes of physics touches a verb we
must define objects before we define
motion because only objects can perform
motions you cannot have a concept like
love perform motion you cannot have a
concept such as intelligence perform
motion in great measure because they're
already concepts that are in motion they
are dynamic concepts to begin with okay
that's the main issue
but then we have touch requires two
objects you need to have two offices
come together in touch and so you need
two objects when you're trying to define
what an object is so you're you're
you're talking about not only a verb but
you're talking about getting two objects
to do that verb okay you need to you
need you need the asteroid to hit the
bone before you can call either one of
them an object that's the problem okay
so it's a circular definition you do
I've just did you find one and again you
know touch means two objects right it's
gonna make contact and the conclusion
the verb must touch invokes two of the
two objects and motion to define the
word object okay so it's a circular
definition and again you have to define
object before you use any kind of verb
as part of the definition of the word
object so yeah you can't use touch or C
C is also a verb by the way for those
who don't know grammar so you can't say
I can't see the rope
well yeah it's irrelevant because that's
not the definition of the word object
for the purposes of physics so define
object other in in the alternative if
it's not shape okay it's not uh if you
can't define it with that criteria okay
here's another comment along the same
lines also because all these people with
the only thing they can think about is C
and touch that's all that comes to their
mind okay and what is the thickness of
the electromagnetic ropes the thickness
like that's important you know I don't
know it's very thin we don't care about
numbers in physics that that doesn't
explain anything it's very thin is that
close enough and says how can every atom
be attached to every other atom without
it becoming a bear garden of tangled
confusion again these people are
thinking of touch and the same question
here all he's got to do all this fella
has to do is define the word object for
the purposes of physics and hopefully he
doesn't define it in terms of touch and
that's that's it that's that's the only
thing that we need to address
that's why you know it's it's fruit
fruitless to talk to these people unless
they understand the definition of the
word object and it takes two years like
I say for a Mathemagician to understand
what the word object means because they
never deal with objects they do with
numbers and they think they're doing a
representation of the real world
especially mechanisms they're not all
they're doing is described and you're
not explaining the mechanism in order to
explain you need to make a movie what
are you gonna put in a movie hopefully
you put objects and not numbers okay so
another comment always along the same
lines here's here's another file and he
says ropes are observable objects
observable you get or observe right you
gotta use your eyes right gravity itself
is not observable okay so uh so you
can't observe
gravity but ropes are observable so so
we got an issue here because if you can
observe the rope right if you go to the
lab or the or you do an experiment in
the field somewhere and you say ah I
observe gravity I saw the rope or
whatever then for sure you have not seen
gravity because like he says there
gravity should not be observable if you
see gravity I don't know what planet
you're in but hopefully you haven't
taken too much you know booze okay no
hopefully what we're trying to answer is
the invisible stuff and untouchable
stuff that mother nature uses and so if
you see or touch something out there and
say I touch gravity I I touch
I saw the mediator of gravity or of
magnetism well then you haven't touched
gravity or the media you're a grand hub
of magnetism okay all we can observe
about it is its effects yes and
invisible ropes he says have you ever
observed such a thing hopefully not
hopefully I mean after ten beers I'm a
gay I can make an effort maybe see the
ropes but hopefully I should not be able
to see the ropes when I when I look at
grip when I analyze gravity
whatever you know if I let go of the pen
as I always do my little experiment here
you know you get a pen you let it go
and it falls to the floor okay and if
that's the case I should not see what
cold or pushed on it by the way push we
got the same thing I mean these people
never ask the question they should have
asked and that is assuming you're gonna
simulate gravity with particles have you
seen the particles of gravity have you
seen the gravitons pushing on the pen
pretty sample but they never asked that
question it's it's only one that you
introduce the ropes and say look we're
gonna do this with Road instead of push
we're gonna do it with pull these are
but I don't see I can't touch the rope
well you couldn't see or touch the
particles that pushed either why did you
ask the question then why did you ask
the the person in quantum mechanics or
the person in general relativity where
are the part of why can't I see the
particles that you're using to push okay
and see they never asked that question
for some reason that question only pops
up when they're analyzing the rope how
come they don't get tangled well how
come you didn't ask that question about
quantum mechanics how come the gravitons
can be it that many of them at the same
place at the same time
how can one particle can be at two
places at once
nobody has those questions those are not
valid questions for the particle world I
mean you know how come these people ask
only about the rope and only in the
context of the Rope model they never ask
those same questions to the quantum or
the relativist mathematicians okay so
that's where you got to start you got to
ask them the question first before you
come here when you can tell me that you
saw the particles and you saw many
particles at the same location at the
same time or you saw particles going
through each other or then one particle
can be in two places at once when you
can show me you know that that you got
proof for that evidence other than
testimony from an idiot the math magics
you know if you can show me prove an
experiment where we can all take a look
at see
all these particles occupy the same
location you know unless you can come
with all that evidence here you got
nothing you get absolutely not you can't
even ask the question okay
first ask the question the quantum how
do particles occupy a single space how
does one particle occupied many spaces
okay and that's when you take William of
Ockham you go with the least number of
assumptions so you know we never say
that a rope can be at two places at once
for example so that's what quantum says
that they're particles can be at two
places at once ask that question first
yes get that problem resolved before you
come here okay that's the way it works
and again he talks about seeing and then
he goes into is simply gravity is a
force a force a force is a force that we
cover that the other day you know what
is a force versus a concept but he says
more than a concept more than a concept
I don't know kasa plus when he thinks
it's an object he's trading forces in
the hobby he says that's a real object
whereas the rope is a you know just like
we saw the other day a rope is an
assumption and because it's an
assumptions not a real object on the
other hand this concept called force we
know it's real we know it exists why
because there was this force that blew
my house down well yeah but maybe it was
the air you know I mean where was the
floor what force are you talking about
see what these people say or what
they're thinking is you know you have a
horse pull on the Clark or you have an
elephant push on the cart so they say
okay here we needed an elephant here we
needed a horse we can see those and so
they generalize you know and they say
well you know what move the car truly is
a force okay so they don't worry about
the object that did it because it could
be something pulling from the front that
they can see like a horse could be
enough and could be a tractor pushing
could be a group of dogs you know
Huskies pulling on the sled so they they
have all these objects they say okay
we're gonna generalize we're gonna say
your force
move the cart forward and they forget
about the object but see that's because
you can see all these objects now when
you come to gravity now you get a little
bit of problem because you can't see the
mediator and they continue to introduce
the word force they say well here's the
force that moved the ball down to the
center of the earth or to the ground you
say ok but when push the ball or what
pull down the ball in either case it
doesn't matter and at that point they
say a force yeah you can't use the word
for us now we need to identify the
physical artifact that's pushing the
ball or the donkey that's pulling on the
ball now we need to identify that
physical object that's mediating that
transaction and if you say there is no
object because I can't see or touch it
then you're in effect introducing
spirits in that same space you're doing
it with black magic you're saying
there's nothing there and the ball is
being pushed or pulled by what spirits I
mean you know what are you gonna put in
that area and that's what these people
have in their mind gravity is a force
more than a concept as we can observe
its effects on objects of mass yeah
they're just worried about the cart the
fact that the cart moved and not what
moved the cart that's the problem ok so
yeah we have a problem with all these
people because they are irrational
individuals yeah yeah
here's another comment ok think from the
same fella we can we cannot find and
when we cannot find an object in nature
that can be likened unto an invisible
construct we need to avoid introducing
observable constructs that describe a
concert that it is itself not observable
ok so you're saying if we can't see it
we can't touch it then we don't then we
should not introduce objects in that
area in other words it's gonna do spirit
here do black magic he's gonna say that
the cart we can see and we can see the
elephant pushing or the or the horse
pulling we can see those so he says that
that's we can make sense of that because
we can see every object but we can't see
certain object
then they don't exist and you should not
mediate that with objects oh how about
the air I mean you know the air blows on
your face right blows your hair up and
down maybe right so what moved your hair
you can't see it so because you can't
see it it's not an object and forget
about detective because now we're
talking about only seeing so seeing it
cannot be a criterion here you can see
that we cannot use the word C as a
criterion for that invisible stuff
because you can't see it
peri so so you know you're not observing
you're not using your eyes you can't see
air fortunately right except in New York
City sometimes you know
but he says definitions are not the
solution we're not gonna use definitions
he says don't use definitions because
they destroyed my religion and he talks
about truth and of course he says that
they use this logic system to talk about
things like infinity what logic infinity
is irrational only mental patients use
the word infinity and say it's logical
logical to what not in the physical
world in mathematics you can say
whatever you want you can say that you
know time is infinite and motion is
infinite and you can say whatever the
number line is infinite in math you can
get away with whatever you want because
they're all abstractions but when you
come into physics now we're talking
about something else
now you can't use the word infinite or
infinity as we've discussed not past
three or four sessions because infinity
is an irrational term infinite is an
adjective
infinity is that adjective turned into a
noun that's what they've done they
turned an adjective into a noun and now
they talk about infinity some location
Land of Oz where you go or I don't know
the end of the rainbow I don't know what
infinity is what is infinity infinity is
a place of location where you go there
and say oh this is infinity so so we
don't have any use for the word infinity
and we don't have in fact any use for
the word infinite either
right because in physics we define
object as that which has shape and there
is no object that is infinite like
infinite triangle how do you know it
some triangle if it's infinite you know
like well I was going to discuss that
later on but just real quick you know
Euclid and all the Greeks essentially
they talked about the plane being
infinite if the plane is infinite what
kind of plane is it is it a circle is it
a square is it a triangle what's the
shape of that plane if it's infinite in
every direction ok so this is the
problem the problem is that this word
infinite has no place in science
it only has place with abstractions in
mathematics it's like just used to say
yeah I can count forever and the correct
word is incessant you can insult out
incessantly that's what it is that's
what a number is the number the word
number means to count it's a it's a verb
it's not a noun but they treat it if the
mathematicians have turned it into a
noun they say number no no there's no
such noun as known number not in not in
the real in science in ordinary speech
you can say whatever you want in science
the word number means to count it's a
verb so and they turned it into the now
number they turn turn the word in
infinite into the verb infinity the
adjective infinite into the noun
infinity to talk about what incessant
counting that's what it is that's how
that's how all this development anyways
he talks about truth logic and infinity
obviously has very little understanding
of physics but it's interesting that
this fellow also talks about
observations okay now he just mentioned
that you cannot observe gravity okay
and he said you refuse to make
observations which are called
experiments okay yeah we have no use in
science for observations or
Spearman's because science is about
explaining and not about a gawking
observing and gawking or about doing
experiments here you know I do
gazillion experiments I let go to the
pen okay always falls to the floor okay
so I did a million experiments and what
did I learn because you do repeatable
experiments you know you understand you
understand how gravity works what the
mechanism is just by doing experiments I
mean we've been doing experiments with
gravity now at least four hundred five
hundred years if not much longer people
knew that the apples fall to the floor
from the tree since the days at least of
the Greeks and they probably pondered
this you know how does this work what is
pulling it down and they never addressed
that because they didn't have enough
understanding of gravity or anything
like that but that's what they did they
they saw it they understood gravity in
that sense that's something that
everything falls downwards for some
reason they could not explain it and
they probably had a word for gravity I
guess you know they probably say oh yeah
that fell to the ground one gravity and
that's all they could say because they
didn't understand so the fact that you
do a repeatable experiment you stand you
know looking at the tree and you see all
these rotten apples just slowly follow
one flaws the other one follows the
other one so you did observe observation
you did experiment and what's causing
the the mechanism what what brings the
Apple down doing do we still know so no
experiments and observations have
nothing to do with science we do not
gawk in science we have to explain
that's why observation experiment and
math have nothing to do with physics or
with science okay we don't do
experiments you want to experiments
that's technology that has nothing to do
with science science we have to explain
what a magnetic field is and how a
magnet attracts another that's the type
of thing we have to answer in science
okay
and so again repeatable observations you
know and he says that's the first step
in the scientific method well I don't
know the scientific process I guess he
meant the the method as well right and
no there's no provision for for that in
the scientific method here's a
scientific method okay here it is you
see it okay and stepwise us
assumptions you need to have the objects
the definitions and the initial scene
where in there do you see a provision
for observations for gawking and for
repeatability and all this nonsense that
he put in there now there there is no
the first step is there that's of step
one its assumptions okay you need to you
need to present the objects that you're
going to be using to be to explain your
theory that's what science is about
scientific method is explanation you
have to have a way of explaining
something right in a rational manner to
another human being what is rational
that you do not move concepts around
primary part of that definition primary
criterion okay there are others as well
and you got to use your definitions
consist of me etc etc but the point here
is that the first step of the scientific
method is the assumptions you know
detective goes to a crime scene the
first thing he has to do is describe the
scene okay and those are his assumption
because he can describe the scene but
when the prosecutor comes to court to
present his case you know the the people
there no one has been at the crime scene
so he's got a paint a picture of what
he's what the police men saw when they
can your detectives saw when they came
here and it may be the defense attorney
paints a different picture he says no I
saw something different when I went
there so they have different assumptions
there are different assumptions of what
the foundations of each of those
theories will be based on and so yeah
the first step is assumptions you have
to tell the jury what objects were
involved you know there was a murder was
that a knife was it a gun was it poison
you know you got to present the objects
those are the objects without that you
just can't go into your theory and start
explaining oh this is what we think we
had happened no we still don't know what
happened what happened first then you
can tell how it happened that's the
theory okay so no these people want to
skip over these steps
they say we don't need the objects we
don't need the definitions I'm gonna go
directly to the theory this is the issue
okay okay
and this Falcons continuing he talks
about first cause Easter it's
interesting that he says that you need
observation but then he says we have
never observed an existence spawn to
being spontaneously in other words
nothing ever turned from space into an
object spontaneously all on its own so
he's saying we need a creator
well I'll even grant the creator let's
grant the Creator okay we have this
all-powerful magician okay I wouldn't do
the mechanism okay
so if the creator or maybe an alien from
another planet who is super intelligent
whatever I don't care
and have super technology right we bring
him over and he's gonna go in there and
he's gonna say let me show you how I
create something from nothing he goes
waves his magic wand goes poof and a
rabbit appears in front of you okay okay
there was nothing as soon as we do this
in space with us you know vacuum total
vacuum case suddenly you're a rabbit
appears in front of you fine okay so he
made the Trekkie he promised he was
gonna make that trick he did it now I
want to know the mechanism please
explain the mechanism dear God dear
Klingon tell me how you did it how did
you convert something into nothing
that's what I need to know if you cannot
tell me that then you're imagining
non-set you've seen too many Hollywood
movies that's your problem
nothing cannot something cannot come
from nothing and nothing something
cannot turn into nothing okay something
is that which has shape that which has
shape cannot lose length width and
height or at least two of those dyed
mentions and turn into nothing by what
process explained the process don't tell
me you can just tell me the process I
need to know the mechanism and if you
can't tell me the mechanism then this
nonsense about creating even with your
magician does not work
you got to tell me the process and of
course he's assuming there's a creator
but then as always you know these
because atheists have many years argued
you know who created the creator we get
the same problem and if you're gonna say
well the Creed is infinite at the end
creators are the eternal he's always
been around well we don't need the
Creator for that matter we can say
matter has been around because matter
cannot turn into space space cannot turn
into matter something cannot turn into
nothing nothing cannot turn into
something
therefore matter has always been there
there is no moment of creation of matter
except in the religion of mathematical
physics where they talk about BIGBANG
and energy hitting energy and separating
all this nonsense okay other than that
you know in a rational folk they don't
believe in and they don't accept the
theory the explanation that matter
popped in from a concept such as energy
or whatever these people come up with
now matter has always been there and
matter will always be there because we
have no way of converting matter into
space we have no way of converting
something into nothing that which has
shape into that which doesn't have shape
that which has shape has length width
and height at least in the real world we
cannot have it lose length width and
height and turn into nothing how do you
do what's the process just explain the
mechanism and I and I'll I'll eat my
words all you gotta do is explain the
mechanism if you cannot explain the
Meccan and you're dreaming you're
talking about religion you're you're an
irrational individual okay what did you
say it talks about faith creation and
yeah you get religious people who just
pounced on this side and they start
talking nonsense that's what it is it's
irrational people and they believe in
creation they believe that you can
create something from nothing because
everything that exists had to have a
cause well the cause are the first cause
what caused caused him or it or whatever
or her but let me give you a little
something under the wrote one okay
for those of you who are more or less
familiar with a rope model here's the
the underlying hypothesis we have a
single closed loop thread in the
universe that's all there is if we were
to unwind or disentangle or disassemble
every atom in the universe okay we would
end up with a single closed loop friend
okay
and that's the starting point now I'm
not saying we can reach that I'm just
saying just imagine let's make believe
for a second okay so there's there's
only a single thread this thread twines
around itself and eventually creates
atoms okay
and these atoms are connected also by
these twine threads so we have the atoms
made of threads and they continue to
another atom through what we call the
electromagnetic rope which is a twine
thread which then immediately Forks out
into another atom and so on down the
line
and all we have in the universe is just
threads working in two atoms and then
unforgiven the ropes that's all we have
now let's just look at a possibility
here
all those on the bottom you can think of
those as galaxies you can think of them
as atoms it doesn't matter they're all
interconnected they're physically
interconnected that's our universe there
and if if that's true then the question
is can all that mesh you disentangle
itself okay now personally I don't think
it can yeah I cannot imagine how I can
disentangle I think it's there forever
okay it's always been there forever and
old me will be there forever
there was no moment of creation people
have no no way of conceptualizing
something that doesn't have a starting
line and this is the big problem that
they have do they have a serious problem
just like they have a big problem with
touch and see they say but I can't see
gravity I can't touch gravity so there's
nothing there and that's an issue of
definitions its shape and not see your
touch likewise all these people have a
problem a serious um problem and I think
most people will have that matter has
always been
and let me tell you one serious problem
with that okay and now you got it really
get a beer is really you know because
it's gonna shock you there's never been
a first human a first living entity
human living entity doesn't matter
really before us trillions trillions
trillions I'm using word truly a
trillions of years ago before the Big
Bang all that nonsense of mathematical
physics there were other atoms forming
other planets or other stars etc etc and
in that trillions of years ago there
were probably human fair very lightly
were humans
and trillions of years before that there
were other humans and trillion years
before that there were other humans I
hope you understand what I'm saying
there was no first human in the universe
and I hope that blew your mind a little
bit if you understood what I'm saying
there was no first human before the the
last human that was born before us there
were others before them before there
were others before that were others and
there were other planets there were
other living things in different planets
around the universe and you just keep
going back back back back there was a
starting point I want to know what the
starting point is you have two
possibilities there was a starting point
or there wasn't and I'll just give you a
scenario for the starting point okay not
that I agree with that I doubt it but
I'm gonna give it to you anyways okay
let's assume we disentangle all the
matter we end up with that closed loop
thread so let's assume that over the
century centuries we're talking about
trillions of years at least
so gazillions of years all the matter in
the universe disentangle x' and turns
into this thread doesn't have to be
perfect thread it could be just weakly
near but it's a closed loop last so
whatever you want to call it okay
and now it begins to tangle again turn
into atoms
ROK's and we end up with a universe in
which we have again stars planets and
atoms
it starts with atoms that works its way
up and we have another universe
essentially we've recreated the universe
now after trillions of trillions of
gazillions of years it disentangled
again we end up with this loose
closed-loop thread okay and now a new
universe begins only in that sense can
you understand a beginning of the the
first human or the first living entities
somewhere when that thread comes in
forms atoms and then again from those
atoms you have you can say a new
universe otherwise the thread itself is
always there okay and more than likely
the universe never disentangle I cannot
imagine
I'll give you gazillions of years as as
much as your computer will as many zeros
as your computer can handle and I don't
think you can disentangle all the matter
in the universe I just have a problem
with that but that's just my version of
it but if you're gonna ponder a first
human or a first living entity or first
son a first atom you can talk about
anything here if you're gonna talk about
the first atom created well you can
think of that as the thread that has
untangled and now when it's tangling it
forms atoms ropes and from there on
forms all the matter in the universe and
so this answers a question that another
fellow asked here another comment and it
goes something like this fellow says you
didn't have good English but we can
still try to make sense of what he used
to try and say yes if all universe
formed formed by a single
electromagnetic thread then why so many
different things we can't visualize
further we can't visualize further how
different things are formed from single
electromagnetic thread how the single
electromagnetic thread formed different
thing
and yeah the the threat just forms atoms
and it's from atoms that we're going to
you know form things the table is made
out of atoms the wall is made out of
atoms tree is made out of atoms the rock
the dog everything is made out of atoms
okay and so there are different types of
atoms the atoms that make up a living
entity such as a dog right are not the
same atoms that make up the silicon in
your wall so there are different kinds
of atoms they're all made out of
electromagnetic threads according to our
theory you know but the issue is that
they're not the same types of atoms so
you can build different kinds of
entities living entities here and inner
entities there because they're using
different kinds of atom you know you
won't see life-forms made out of silicon
and people's a lot of people speculate
on that say oh yeah there could be in
other planets or in another part of the
universe silicon based intelligent
creatures and I say no no way absolutely
no way and you know that's a lot of
Hollywood dreaming but the issue here is
that you cannot produce silicon
life-forms and one way that you can
prove that to yourself with a little bit
of evidence just go through the solar
system you got on a silicon there no
living entity officially made out of
silicon will be found there the only
thing we can find made out of that
that's living is made out of carbon okay
so there are there are known living
entities made out of silicon silicon as
the primary chemical element and we got
a lot of silicon in the solar system
it's strange that nothing developed
there and I'm sure if we go to another
planet we would find the same thing if
we go to another planet we'll find
carbon based life because I think life
is strictly carbon-based you won't find
silicon-based life just to mention one
chemical element you mention any others
as far as I'm concerned it's the same
there are no life-forms that are non
carbon-based at least I cannot imagine
but if you can build one in the lab and
show us how it crawls out of the flask
like we had a couple of scientists in
the 50s okay hurry and Miller and he ran
an experiment where they put carbon in
this flask zapped it with electricity
and well they didn't have a bug crawl
out of there but they did create amino
acids which is a good way of showing
that there was a possibility that there
were chemical reaction that started the
life process on earth and if you can do
something similar with silicon it would
be great but I don't think I cannot
imagine silicon-based life-form but if
you want to imagine well yeah but it's
no good because there's no way first
that you can prove it you can only
fantasize about it that's all you can do
that's great I don't know what use that
is you know it's a speculation okay okay
so what's the issue the the bottom line
here is that anyone who wants to come to
this channel and put a comment and once
it answered he's got to define the word
object we do need objects to do physics
and the first thing is tell me what an
object is define the word object if you
cannot define the word object and we
have to them or defend it you know you
can have your your definition say Oh
objects is that which moves or that
would test mass or will that which has
color you can say whatever you want and
I show that you can't use any of those
but we'll be glad to tear your
definition apart so let's start there
let's have you defend your definition of
object before you make a comment but if
you're just gonna make a comment about
your beliefs your religion yeah sure go
ahead but I'm only going to address
people who who can justify their
definition of object show why the
definition of shape is wrong and why
they need to introduce see and touch
especially especially those two because
those are the ones that they use
informally when they attack the rock
model they say oh but I can
see the rope and I can't touch the rope
yeah because that's not what an object
is for the purposes of physical object
is not that which you can touch or see
that's why you you're using wrong you're
attacking a strong man you're saying I
can't touch and see the Rope yeah
because that's not what an object is an
object is that which has shape and not
that which you can touch or see so
you're using the wrong criteria you're
using the wrong properties you're
extrapolating properties of ordinary
speech of your ordinary experience with
the things that you see in touch and you
say well I can't see what mediates
gravity yeah because that's the way
mother nature made our universe
fortunately you know can you imagine if
she would have made even even particles
let's do it the particles I mean you
don't like the ropes the super particle
imagine she made the particles of
gravity visible and touchable we'd be
bombarded with bullets every two seconds
we'd be done all those gravity tea-party
all those gravitons that are hitting me
no she was smart she said we got to be
we've got to make the graviton invisible
and intangible okay and likewise we have
to make the ropes invisible and
intangible and so anyone who talks about
tangibility and about invisibility you
know he's gotta start with the word
object he's got to know what an object
is let me show you some of the problems
that that these people have because he
turns out that when you you people ask
questions then they go like did Quora I
am writing Cora quite a few articles try
to write one every so often when I get
the time and people go there and ask
questions men you know they wanna know
certain things and they ask qualitative
type questions they don't they want you
to give them an equation
some people do but most people say they
just tell me how this works
tell me the mechanism I was like work
and here's a like here's here's a set of
questions that I pulled out just at
random today because it more of us had
to do with a subject matter okay and the
first question area it gives it to you
in a nutshell so why can phones pass
through each other
good person well addressing the others
yet
how can so-so photons go through each
other and and these people in it's like
nobody asks questions about like okay so
photons go through each other they can
also be in two places at once if they
tell you there's nobody questions that
but as soon as I say the roads can cross
through each other what do you mean they
don't get tangled oh why don't you ask
the question here here's where you ask
the questions hey you know what's
interesting about all these questions
here you see lists here why does light
pass through class
why does infrared radiation not travel
through glass why are we able to see
through materials like glass why can we
see through glass but can't see through
wood or steel these are very important
but these are very basic questions you
know the problem the first big problem
all the big names in Quora I'm gonna
mention any of them you can look them up
just look up the word physics for quorum
find out who the physicists are who have
millions of hits right and see if any of
them answer to any of these questions
and none of them do
they all avoid they talk about idiocy
such as quantum particles when they give
you equations but here this is something
simple why don't they answer these
questions why do they avoid them all
these simple questions how a magnet
attracts another how light avoids how
photons go through each other you'll
never see their names there ask them ask
you know find one of these physicists
so-called physicists big name for them
people who answer physics question and
ask them to answer that question see if
see if they'll tackle it okay so what
happened today with my son we did a
little experiment okay and why do we did
the experiment because of this in the
book the book that the rope hypothesis I
put this picture in there if you look
down three meters of water in a pool
right you can see your reflection down
at the bottom okay
now people say well now you're not
really looking at the bottom of what's
reflecting is the top of the water
you're looking what's reflecting your
face is the surface of the water
dang a lot of people have this idea well
first you'd be wrong because you can see
you can see with your own eyes the drain
the dark drain and one of the corners of
the pool you'll see it right through the
water and hopefully that's not on the
surface okay so that's the first problem
but then I had to show that this is also
true that you can see your reflection at
the bottom of the pool
whereas you cannot see your face through
through a sheet of paper through a thin
sheet of paper okay and so this would
the experiment was about it's a very
expensive experiment don't try it at
home unless you're in the company of a
trained relativist okay it's a very
dangerous experiment very expensive okay
so your discretion is advised
okay so here it goes first we went in
there and we put a mirror okay we put a
mirror and we filmed it okay we filmed
it with the camera you can see the
camera okay films itself okay in the
mirror okay and then we put a sheet of
paper and you can see that it blocks the
camera there's no reflection now okay so
the light does not go through the piece
of paper and the mirror does not reflect
through the piece of paper to our camera
okay so we can film this back and forth
okay and you can see that the paper
blocks any reflection you do not in
other words light does not go through
the paper and and that's a very thin
sheet of paper here it is that's the one
we use I mean I hope you can see how
thin that thing is yes
it's very thin not even a millimeter
maybe my micrometer I don't know I
haven't measured it but it's thick you
can't see - I see a paper in fact here
it is can you see me
hopefully that blocked the light it is
does not the image my image does not go
through the paper okay so hopefully I've
established that you can do this very
expensive very dangerous experiment in
your own dark basement and here okay
here we did the experiment now with
water okay so check closely I cleaned my
trashcan my kitchen trash can
what we did was film and we can see
right through about a cubic feet of
length of water which is from your elbow
to your the tip of your fingers that's
how deep that trash can was okay so the
trash can is a little less than maybe
two feet something like that deep we
filled it with water right on top of the
e/m mirror okay and right through the
water once once we stabilize the water
you can see yourself at the bottom of
that pool okay you can see your image
there so so the mirror reflects right
through the water so it's not that the
you're seeing your reflection at the
surface of the water you're seeing
yourself at the bottom of the pool okay
that's the point of this experiment that
means that water which is you can see
much thicker in this case then the
little sheet of paper I mean how much
how much water do we have there you know
again about two feet of water that's how
deep that was okay so you have two feet
of water all these atoms all these
molecules in your way and light goes
both ways it goes from your image to the
mirror and back to your pure face
because you can see yourself in the
mirror down down below and that same
thing cannot go through a thin sheet of
paper that image you know you can't see
me through there and I can't see so is
it the quantity of atoms that blocks
light is that what it is
well obviously not see when these people
I ask these questions why can like go
through glass
what are you gonna answer what are you
gonna tell your ten-year-old kid you
know why what's the cause what's the
mechanism that's like go through the
window or not you say well yeah sure it
does well that's only if you use
particles then you talk about going
through and of course you run into
millions of problems anyone using
particles because now you get it is to
talk about hit and miss how do they
explain these things well the way they
explain them today they don't explain
them again none of the big name
so-called physicists mathematical
physics whatever they are gets into
coral to answer these questions you'll
never find an answer from a big-name guy
you know guy that's got some authority
because they can't answer the question
they can't rationalize it with good
particles what were the notions that
they have that they suggest the theory
the explanations of physical
interpretation well one of them is that
the photon flick on ball right because
it turns into a ball right is absorbed
by the atom and then the atom releases
the photon in a different direction so
you know light goes through the window
and it hits a atom the atom absorbs the
photon the energy whatever nonsense word
they put in there and then it releases
it back again that's how you're gonna
explain reflection or you can explain
the refraction okay and another point is
that it functions like a pinball machine
you have the photon and goes bouncing
between atoms
okay so bounces between them and then
comes out and why is that important well
because they're trying to explain the
speed they're saying well why does light
go slower through denser material like
in the case of glass and I've told you
because I've worked many years in a
glass
sio2 okay we had to build layers of
oxide over silicon silicon silicon
dioxide that's the name of it came for
glass and we have measured these thin
films and we measure them with another
Samet err light went in there came out
and the machine to tell you the
thickness of that layer of oxide why
because according to official religion
it's not even an explanation they use
something called the refractive index
that means that light goes slower light
go slower light moves slower
throw the film and then comes back out
in the air and now goes faster again and
what they cannot explain is that
acceleration we and all understand you
know you crash your car against the tree
you go a little slower we can all
understand that so here you have light
going through air which does not provide
too much resistance too much friction to
the photons right to the stream of
photons it hits glass and now there's
more solid stuff there so now light
crashed against the tree right go slower
reflex on the bottom layer and we use
silicon underneath the silicon dioxide
hits the silicon bounces back up through
the layer always slow through the
through the layer and it moves fast
again well why did it move fast again
what speeded it up where did it get its
energy to go faster and they cannot
explain that they can I explained with
particles and here's a here's an image
of that so that you can see visually
what I'm talking about see if I can get
it here okay this is what they they have
in mind you have a layer of silicon
which is the very part at the bottom you
have silicon dioxide which has been
grown on that film okay it's a very thin
film and you're gonna try to measure the
thickness of that film we use an ellipse
ometer but we don't need to know any of
that all you need to know is that if we
shine light
on the surface of that glass that upper
part is glass right they say that the
angle changes the angle of the particles
or waves going in their changes and then
when it comes out as you can see it goes
slowly through the through the glass and
then when it comes out it goes faster
again it goes that the same speed it was
company it had come in and the question
is what speeds it back up and here I've
labeled these so that you can see a
little more detail what I'm talking
about okay you can see velocity one
coming in and then it turns to velocity
two which is slower and then goes back
to velocity one which is faster and they
just used Snell's law okay
and so what they do is they just say
look we can calculate it we can tell you
how slow light went through the film
okay yeah but you're not telling me the
mechanism is it little balls is that
what it is is that what light is is
light just a bunch of tiny balls we have
to identify this I mean you have to
identify the invisible medium you're the
actor you have to identify the actor and
they don't want to identify the actor
because if they identify the actor as a
particle then they cannot explain this
and there's no way they're gonna explain
it with particles okay so how do we do
it in rational science okay here you see
the mechanism in rational science for
comparison you reach your own
conclusions I mean you know how we tell
you is what our mechanism is okay oh
sorry
this I wanted to show that a reflection
in the in the lake or in the ocean or
whatever is not just the surface problem
that is you can by putting a mirror at
the bottom of the lake you can if it's
clear enough you'll see your face okay
but here it is here's my mechanism for
this okay here you see it okay
there's no particles moving in or moving
out all you have is torsion from atoms
to atoms and light travels always at the
same speed because what changes in this
case
is the frequency in exchange for
wavelength but little C 300,000
kilometers per second is always the same
and here I have labeled this as well so
that you are well aware of what I'm
referring to here here it's labeled okay
you have the short links okay and
belongings the long links are the ones
that go through the whatever medium a
denser medium you have C little C is
always equal to frequency times
wavelength that's the equation down
there if you increase the frequency the
wavelength goes down and if you increase
the wavelength the frequency goes down
and what we called it is we call it link
length okay and yeah you have sio2 you
have all you have is torsion and so
there is no motion in the sense of
moving from A to B light does not the
rope does not travel the rope stays in
place is just torques from atom to atom
and all you're doing is changing the
frequency for the wavelength and that's
why you did the light when it comes back
out to say to use that terminology is at
the same speed as when it came in and
it's also at the same speed within the
the denser medium why because there is
no such thing as miss torsion is always
going to be the same speed always the
only thing that changes is the frequency
in exchange for the wavelength and
that's the mechanism you know I have to
believe it you just have to understand
it you reach your own conclusions in
your dark basement if you think you can
figure this out by running experiments
you're wrong there is no experiment you
can run to verify an invisible
intangible unsellable untestable
unhearable entity you cannot use your
five senses you cannot use experiments
to address this issue you're not going
to find out what light what gravity what
magnetism is through an experiment we've
done all the experiments I'm sure mr.
Faraday who worked many years
after David died he took over the
laboratory over there and and he started
doing all kinds of experiments with
magnets just about all the ones that he
could think about we did a few more
after that but he did quite a bit he
tested magnets on electricity until he
dropped dead and he couldn't figure out
through experiments what what
electricity is or what magnetism is and
so today we have this irrational
interpretation of electricity as the
flow of electrons why is it irrational
because they cannot they cannot draw the
atom before they do their mechanism I
need a picture of the atom and the
picture of the atom has to show why the
electron bead is tied to the nucleus
that's what you got a show if you cannot
explain what binds the electron to the
nucleus you cannot tell me what keeps it
there why does it spontaneously fly away
and turn into an ion you cannot explain
that you can't even start to tell us
anything about electricity electricity
is not the flow of beads because you can
justify it and the question no one has
been able to justify the atom to begin
with and so you're basing electricity an
atom that you cannot justify that's the
issue the issue is the electron bead
would have to have some way of sticking
to the nucleus before you set it in
motion through a potential to use that
terminology so this is the issue the
issue is we don't know what our tricity
is they don't know what magnetism is
they don't know what gravity is they
don't know what light is they don't know
any of these things and the question is
how can they be you know because they
say they've proven in their they know
and they and everybody raised their
hands and voted for these theories right
and if that's the case it's very simple
just explain these simple things why
does why does light go through glass
that's all you got explain how you know
here tell me why light doesn't go
through
this piece of paper and why light goes
through glass why this glass
I like the answer one guy gave he says
well the reason light goes through glass
is because it's translucent and those
are the kinds of answer these irrational
individuals give you now you gotta give
me a mechanism how does like do it and
under the Rope models very simple light
does not go through light does not go
through a window light does not go
through a window the rope ends in an
atom which retransmits relays the the
signal that received to your eyes so you
so the light of a Sun that reaches your
eyes is through a window is reaching
your eyes indirectly because it's the
atom in the glass is retransmitting a
signal the torsion signal it received
its retransmitting it through Quantum
Jumping it's being stimulated by the
frequency that the Sun gave that torsion
the atom pumps at a faster rate with the
Sun than at night and it's
retransmitting that to your eye that
same frequency to your eye
to the atom in your eyes so it's all
connected it's all through a channel
known as the the channels gazillions of
channels that these ropes are and you
say I can't touch him I can't see him
you're an irrational individual you have
to start by doing what an object is an
object is not that which you can touch
your see now it is that which has shape
okay let's see do I still have time no I
don't have time for any more again I'm
gonna have to postpone you quit and good
old mr. Aristotle to next time okay
we'll see you then what is it on Sunday
we'll see that right and by the way
those people who can translate the book
please contact us at okok akkad at
hotmail.com and we're gonna start our
Spanish channel now in more
and so we're gonna be notifying people
in different parts of the world that
they may want to tune in and learn
something we'll see on Sunday
bye bye